angry protests in rochester new york
last night
reacted to a grand jury decision not to
charge
any police officers in the death of a
black man
daniel prud died nearly a year ago after
an arrest caught on video
police physically restrained prude
putting a hood
over his head his family says he was in
a mental health crisis
acting erratically when they called
police
the officers say they followed procedure
our national correspondent jerica duncan
reports on the decision
and we remind you the video of the
arrest is hard to watch
this is the moment a grand jury spent
months focusing on according to retired
new york city police sergeant
joseph jacqueline they're trying to
contain him they're trying to hold them
down
and this becomes the seminal point where
daniel dies and this is where the
attorney general
fails to make her case after the grand
jury decided not to indict any of the
seven officers involved in daniel
prude's death
new york attorney general leticia james
said her office presented the strongest
case possible
we sought a different outcome than the
one the grand jury handed
us today in police body cam videos prude
can be seen handcuffed on the ground
naked wearing a mesh spit hood over his
head as an officer pushes his face
against the ground
and another presses his knee to pru's
back the 41 year old was held down for
about two minutes
until he stopped breathing and was given
cpr
he died a week later from complications
of asphyxia according to the coroner's
report
if you're going after the police
officers in this case for murder
you have to show intent that's
impossible to try to prove into a grand
jury
let alone in a court of law lawyers for
the officers say holding someone to the
ground
is still an approved restraint technique
in the department
as we sit here 11 months to the day
later
the training that these officers
employed the techniques that they
employed
nothing has changed at all in terms of
the rochester police department's stated
policies
in dealing with situations such as this
despite the decision
prude's family is pursuing a civil case
against the officers
there's a different different standards
different burden of proof in that case
and we don't have to prove intentional
conduct there
we can succeed with with negligent or
reckless conduct
and that's a that's a big legal
difference the officers involved are
still on leave pending an internal
police investigation
for cbs this morning i'm jerica duncan
you know it is when it says this video
is difficult to watch that certainly is
a good example of that
i'm just struck by to me the inhumanity
of how this man was treated
yes no blanket no jacket no nothing and
he's just
a hood on the ground a hood on the
ground he's in he's in and he's naked
yeah and he's naked his brother called
for help for him they were trying to get
him help for
mental distress we always hear tony
about following procedure
it makes me think maybe we need to
rethink all the procedures or maybe have
another number besides 9-1-1 when
someone is
exactly clearly has a mental issue
that's extremely upsetting to watch